science welcome to the science asylum I
am Nick lucid I'm sure many of you
noticed seasonal changes here after year
come to think of it you're probably so
used to them you don't even think about
them anymore unless they're you know in
your way or something those types of
changes are different depending on where
you live there isn't a whole lot of
variation in temperature in the tropics
it's warm sometimes and hot other times
it never really gets cold it makes more
sense to discuss a dry season and a
rainy season the arctic areas are mostly
just cold all the time parts can even go
months straight without any sunlight in
the temperate areas though you basically
have four seasons spring summer fall and
winter plants bloom in the spring it
gets hot in the summer trees lose their
leaves in the fall and it gets cold in
the winter but why why does this happen
oh oh it's because earth is closer to
the Sun in the summer right oh no
actually here at 42 degrees north
latitude we're further away from the Sun
in the summer 3.3% further away wrap
your mind around that so why is it so
much colder in the winter because the
earth is tilted it doesn't really matter
how far away the tilt has moved us from
the Sun either again at 42 degrees north
latitude
I'm only tilted about 2100 miles further
away from the Sun in the winter that
might seem like a lot but the earth is
93 million miles from the Sun so 2100
miles is only about two one thousandth
of a percent which is much less than the
3.3 percent we get from orbiting the Sun
and we already said that didn't matter
what the tilt of the earth does is it
changes the angle at which light hits
the ground there's a shallower angle in
the winter so the light is just sort of
grazing the ground in the summer though
the angle is steeper causing the light
to hit the ground more directly what
does that have to do with anything
doesn't the Earth's get the same amount
of light regardless that's actually a
really good question the energy you get
from the Sun is not the same as the
energy the earth gets from the Sun
energy is something you receive as an
amount kind of like money first you want
to know how often you're getting it
knowing you're getting a thousand
dollars isn't very useful is it a
thousand per year a thousand per month a
thousand per week a thousand per second
a thousand per second would be pretty
awesome actually
it matters
when it comes to energy we usually
measure it per second which is where the
watt comes from it also matters how it's
being distributed is it just you
receiving $1 per second or your entire
town if it's your entire town then you
are probably receiving less than a penny
when it comes to energy we usually
measure per square meter if we consider
both of these things then we'll be
measuring joules per second per square
meter or watts per square meter this is
what we call intensity ignoring
complicated things like clouds and other
weather patterns if the earth were flat
and facing the Sun there would be 1365
watts per square meter hitting the
surface of the earth slap a simple
atmosphere in there and that goes down
to about 1,000 watts per square meter
because the atmosphere absorbs some of
the light on its way in fortunately the
earth isn't flat on the winter solstice
you are tilted as far away from the Sun
as possible which means the light is
spread out over the widest area less
energy per square meter means the
intensity is lower on the summer
solstice you're tilted as far toward the
Sun as you ever will be so the sunlight
you're getting is more direct more
energy per square meter means the
intensity is higher this graph is a
rough estimate of the intensity reaching
the Earth's surface at noon here in
Detroit this is a very temperate area
the intensity range is about 530 watts
per square meter
and it doesn't drop below 415 this is
what the graph looks like for the Arctic
Circle you can actually see the
intensity reach zero on the winter
solstice that day literally has zero
sunlight at noon the light at the Tropic
of Cancer looks a little different
notice the graph is flatter in the
summer showing the intensity is more
consistent than it is in the winter the
whole graph is a lot more squished than
the one for Detroit with only a 320 watt
per square meter range that's a lot less
variation making our way to the equator
things get a little weird the light is
actually maximum during the equinoxes
because that's when the Equator is
pointed directly at the Sun and it's
minimum during the solstices because
that's when it's farthest away what
we're seeing here is the gradual
transition from the northern to the
southern hemisphere when the north is in
summer the south is in winter and
vice-versa north-south north-south
north-south see they're opposite to the
ultimate point to this is that while the
earth is always receiving the same
amount of energy from the Sun the summer
people are getting more of it
the winter people so how well do you
handle your seasonal extremes let us
know in the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy